literally all been living vicariously
through you on these red carpet photo
ops I love meeting people that I watch
[Music]
Henry wanted to come down and take a
picture with you we see you there Henry
geeking out over Brad at the SAG Awards
it was his wife who was hoping for a pit
stop
every time we stopped at a red light and
there was another limousine the window
went down and she would yell out the
window Brad are you in there Brad put
the whip put your window down Brad and
then I finally saw him and that was that
moment for you
I played pool yeah he is cool and it's
not just Brad the two performances that
Scarlett gave this year oh my god
extremely Henry's had a pretty amazing
career himself and was honored at the
Paley Center for Media do you have a a
career proudest moment I don't I have
three children I have five grandchildren
and my career is like my other family I
don't have a favorite but there is a
favorite lady in his life his wife Stacy
they got married nearly 42 years ago
we've been together for might be 40 war
yeah right
we finished each other's sentences it's
adorable we're an adorable couple will
you guys let me take a selfie with the
three of us here
[Music]